Oh  I got a granddaughter who likes dressing  up too cute as a button  she loves Peter Pan she always asking  this old timer to read it to her she's  sharp isn't who ideas questions above  the Lost Boys and those pirates probably  because because I never grow old  [Music]  she says to me grandpa are you old  that's it yes we darn I'm older one day  you're gonna be as old as me and this  gets her hair brains all cookin she says  grandma are you gonna die I say yes we  are of course I'm gonna die one day it's  not gonna be today and finally she says  to me grandpa  am I gonna die I have to explain a  question like that Dylan kids  so when all the ween rolls around the  next year there she is  proudest punch she stands up and she  calls grandpa I'm gonna be a pirate  but don't you worry we are  I'll find you  [Music]  [Music]  you